[Applaus]
[Musik]
grüß gott haben sie was gefunden oder
sie was bei uns haben
wer was hat
erhält heute was wertvoll ist habt ihr
was wertvoll ist das ist ein gutes ist
ein fundbüro und nicht irgendwer
selbstbedienungsladen man sie einfach
was also mir egal
ich will nicht schon mal die grauen
immer sehen dass das wenigstens cup
erzeugt ich will dass sie aus den
regalen immer mehr geben aber heute
nicht forcieren muss die ist wohl leicht
haben sie hat in der branche ein
zwitschern oder
was jetzt noch mal zum mitschreiben
entweder sie haben wir es verloren und
syrers hier war es vielleicht ein
ehrlicher finder hier abgeben hat oder
oder sie haben wir es gefunden gäbe es
hier ob damit der rechtmäßige besitzer
hier ob rincon
[Gelächter]
also wenn es mich sofort
also etwas verloren ja und was hans
verloren
die waren die waren meine hobby verloren
diese war rocky marciano i hope computer
dom gamersgate und zu rodeln jetzt
morgen fachhändler für mich
ist die waffen weg also sie haben beim
rodeln eine kaiserliche chinesischem
porzellan börsen aus dem 13 jahrhundert
verloren
und wo soll das krisen seien in china
china erfreulich und wann die miliz die
hochform vom frühschoppen nachholen
prüfung und nach
als man in solchen geräumt diese war sie
haben sie nie besessen geschweige denn
verloren und so gleich dreimal beim
modul
und was machen wir jetzt ist es was wird
scheiben hinten lager noch doch mappus
an die linke schon seit zehn fünfzehn
jahren die heute bestimmt keiner mehr
und vielleicht ist etwas dabei was zu
ihr passt rocky nato smog spezies der -
obst
[Gelächter]
chrysler die leiterin und her doch grid
der straßen
das ist ja unglaublich dass man sich
traut der abt verdreckt in ein fundbüro
zu gehen ganz furchtbar findet ist und
der gestank nicht zum aushalten
charakter bekommt muss hoffen dass man
sich druck will an diesen strecken
gestand gewöhnen und möglich doch
einfach wird das nicht aber man kann ja
was machen aha und was ich so gut wie
mieter bisserl geduld und spucke da
kriegt man jeden träger und jugendliche
stark wie
das
letzte das allerletzte dass alle alle
hinterließ die sehr späte kurze türken
gibt schon tag diesen longyuan in
wohnste zeit so jetzt soll doch
tatsächlich was gefunden was zu ihm
passt
wann gewusst ist mit mir zum chorraum
schritt
großen kissen
abfährt
[Applaus]
[Musik]